hey guys Pete peppers here this video
will contain spoilers HB over at least
some new information today that confirms
a popular fan theory that's been around
for years so if you don't want to know
in the show who John parent John snows
parents are you want to stop watching
right now alright so from the very first
season of the HBO show Game of Thrones
it's been a mystery as to who Jon Snow's
parents are he's a Snow which means he's
a bastard and everything we know about
Ned his father seems to not be in line
with him going off to war and fathering
a bastard so there's been mystery when
Jon first goes to the wall on this scene
here whenever he talks to his father
his father says next time they meet
he'll tell him about his mother and of
course and that dies at the end of
season 1 and they never see each other
again so in the season six finale it's
finally been confirmed and we see Jon
Snow's birth and all this around all the
different things that are going on at
the Tower of joy but if you weren't
following the theories or you haven't
really looked into it too deeply you
might not really understand what this
all means and to make things a little
bit clearer HBO released this
infographic today that shows all the
different connections between the
characters there's a lot of different
information on this I don't know what
you would call I guess you know this
graph and what's really important as far
as this video is concerned is just the
actual parentage and connections between
a few of the different characters so if
we if we just take away all the other
people and we look at Jon his parents
and his connection to Ned we can see
that jon was born between Lyanna stark
and rhaegar targaryen Liana is Ned's
younger sister and Daenerys is Ray gars
younger sister so whenever you think
about the connection between Jon and
Daenerys Daenerys would actually be his
so you there is another line here that
you can see that's the the purple dashed
line and it says abducted and we'll get
into that later but the other thing that
I wanted to mention here is that John is
then in a sense the blood of Fire and
Ice since the Starks are from the north
and the Targaryen czar associated with
dragons and fire so one more thing
that's worth looking at before we get
into the history of who those who his
parents are is that there is no red line
that connects Lyanna and Rhaegar the red
line would show like it goes from Liana
to Robert because she was betrothed to
Robert
they were never a Wed but it also
indicates at least as far as the show is
concerned that Liana and Rhaegar were
not married either that would indicate
that John is still a bastard except for
now he's a Targaryen bastard instead of
a stark bastard Prince Rhaegar Targaryen
was the eldest son of the Mad King Aerys
the second Targaryen being the eldest
son he was the Crown Prince of
Dragonstone and he was also the prince
that was supposed to succeed his father
on the Iron Throne we have several
different descriptions of Rhaegar in the
books and he said to be tall
good-looking dark indigo eyes which is a
common Targaryen trait with long silver
hair I won't go too deeply into his
history for this video but we get a lot
of different things when Daenerys acts
s-sir Barristan Selmy about her brother
her eldest brother and we find out that
he's a good and he's a good knight but
he's also a really intelligent person
and a talented musician as well we also
know that he was somewhat bookish and
became somewhat obsessed with prophecy
at one point and
he was really interested in the idea of
the prince that was promised so
basically he was looking for this
combination of a child born of fire and
ice he was married to Elia Martell
princess of Dorne
she gave him two children but after the
second was unable to have any more so
this inability to have more children may
have preceded the events that went on at
the the great tourney at Harrenhal
Prince Rhaegar won the tourney and when
it came time to crown the queen of love
and beauty he did not choose his own
wife instead he picked Lyanna stark
Liana was betrothed to Robert Baratheon
so this started this basically set in
action the events that led to Robert's
rebellion which took the Targaryen off
of the iron throne join the Battle of
the Trident Robert Baratheon slain
Rhaegar with his Warhammer in single
combat which basically was the decisive
military battle in the rebellion
so since history is written by the
victors the story has always been that
Rhaegar had stolen Liana taking her away
and raped her we hear that story again
and again from different characters
throughout the books in the TV series
but there was a lot of evidence that
made it seem like that wasn't probably
the case Liana seemed to be a willing
participant and they seemed to run away
together to have a child rather than
this abduction story that everyone sort
of perpetuated on the Baratheon saw so
they ran away to the south into the
Tower of joy in Dorne and spent several
months together there until regarde left
to join the battle at the Trident so he
left the pregnant Liana behind with
three of his top Kingsguard to protect
her and the royal child and basically
she's there until Ned and his his
friends ride south to rescue her and
that's the Tower of joy scene that we
see in the TV show
so after Ned arrives at the Tower of joy
and slays Arthur Dayne Sir Arthur Dayne
with the help of Howland Reed he goes
inside to find Liana is bleeding after
giving birth
if you know
you have to pitch
miss manette
oops so this is a big deal for Ned and
it really defines a lot of you know who
he is
throughout the story obviously he had
just married Catelyn whenever he went to
fight in the war and before he left he
got her with child who you know which
was Rob and so he barely knew her in a
way I mean she was actually betrothed to
his brother Brandon so the way things
worked out he left and then he came back
with John Snow and he couldn't really
explain to her because there was too
much risk and he made this promise so it
basically just was the secret that he
had to keep and couldn't tell anything
so we've already mentioned a lot about
Lyanna Stark
and the fact that she was Ned's younger
sister that she was betrothed to Robert
and that she basically was the catalyst
for Robert starting his rebellion we
also know that she was beautiful it said
that she was considered beautiful by all
and we also know that because Rhaegar
crowned her the prince or the queen of
love and beauty also we know that she
was a skilled rider she said that she
rode a horse like a Northman and that
Ned actually compares her in appearance
and sort of her tomboyish in this - Arya
so out of all this the stark children
you know Arya seems to have the the
closest comparison and that actually
says that lianna probably would have
carried a sword sword if their father
had approved of it so that is the story
of Jon Snow's parents there's a bunch of
interesting stuff that goes along with
this and if you look at this a little
bit closer there's a lot of kind of neat
little things the way people are
connected one thing that is interesting
is that whenever Cersei goes to see
Maggie the frog in that prophecy when
she asked was she married the prince
she's actually talking about Prince
Rhaegar Lord Tywin was the hand of the
king and he was hoping to marry off
Cersei - Rhaegar it didn't work out that
way but that's who she grew up basically
being in love with and so we know that
Robert she never really loved Robert and
Robert always had loved Liana
so basically Robert never loved Cersei
and seriously never loved Robert and
they both loved the two people who got
together and our Jon Snow's
it's so that you know it's a it's a big
mystery that's finally been at least as
far as the TV show is concerned solved
Jon Snow is a Targaryen at least by
blood I'm not a hundred percent sure
it's gonna go that way in the books I
mean it's pretty likely now I was always
in the camp of or at least I ended up in
the camp of r+ l equals d and you know
the shardene stuff but you know R plus L
equals J Rhaegar luciana equals John
always made a lot of sense and we'll see
what happens in the book so we don't
really know it's not a guarantee that it
would be the same so I hope you liked
this video please give it a like and
subscribe to my channel I'll be talking
to you soon